COMMITTEE WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY ADD TO THE
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE BEEN SUBMITTED.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. THEN WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE TOO FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ZERO. SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR FOUR FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MONITOR MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION FOR TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF BILLS ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO BILLS. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOT RATED
READY TO ADDRESS. THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE. THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR- YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THINK. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL
MAINTAIN COURT DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AND ANY OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED.
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS. AND CONDUCT A HEARING
CENTERS CLOSE THE SAME
ENTERTAINMENT MATTERS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT AND ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES WILL BE
HEARD TODAY THANK YOU. WE HAVE
FIVE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
HOWEVER A. B. SIX FOUR ONE
HOLDEN. HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S HEARING. WE EXPECT
WE'LL HEAR THAT BILL AT A LATER
DATE- BEFORE WE- HERE
PRESENTATION TO BUILD THE
SYSTEM THE STYLISH QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PRESIDENT DOLLY. DOLLY HERE
SORRY WESSEL HERE WEST OF HERE.
BECKER. FORGES THE PURCHASE
PRESENTS BRADFORD HERE BRADFORD
HERE DOT. EIGHT MEN HERE EIGHT
MEN HERE GONZALEZ. GROWTH.
TWELVE PRESENTS. HERTZBERG.
MIKE WEIR. MAN HERE MAN HERE
RUBIO PRESIDENT RUBIO PRESENTS.
STERN STERN HEAR ME- KERRY HAVE
FORMED. VERY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE-
FIRST AUTHOR TODAY. A SENSE OF-
A. B. SIX FORTY ONE WILL BE
DELAYED TO ANOTHER DAY GOOGLE
STRICTLY- STRAIGHT INTO ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED
AND WE HAVE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
AGUILAR CURRY HERE- ON A BILL
RELATED TO COMMUNICATION
SERVICE EMERGENCIES DISASTERS
REPORTS. WELCOME SOME REMEMBER
WHAT THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE. MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
SEVEN POINTS OF THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGES SEVEN AND
EIGHT OF THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS AS OFTE AS AMENDMENTS
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOUR STAFF. ACTING THAT
LANGUAGE I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A B. ELEVEN HUNDRED
WHICH REQUIRES THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. TO
COLLECT INFORMATION ON
TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS. EFFORTS TO REPAIR
AND REPLACE NETWORK STRUCTURE.
AFTER EMERGENCIES OR DISASTERS.
THE WILDFIRES OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BECAUSE A MASSIVE
DESERT DEVASTATION. HIS NAME A
MASSIVE DEFICIT THE DEVASTATION
FROM PROPERTY LOSS TO
TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS THE
DAMAGE. MANY PEOPLE REPORTED
THAT THE MOBILE PHONES WENT
DARK AND INTERNET SERVICE WENT
OUT TO CELL TOWERS WERE DAMAGED
AN UNDERGROUND FIBER LINES
BURNED. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AN ONLINE SURVEY
FOUND THAT 64% OF RESPONDENTS
IN CINEMA COUNTY AS WILDFIRE
AFFECTED AREAS LOST LAND LINE
PHONE SERVICE. JUST LAST YEAR
THE TWENTY TWENTY WELL THE
GLASS REPORTEDLY DAMAGED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING
DISRUPTIONS AND PHONE SERVICE
IN THE AFFECTED AREA. IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THESE DEVASTATING
FIRES THE STATE AND THE P. U.
C. OUR FOCUS HEAVILY ON THE
UTILITIES RESPONSE TO THIS
MASSIVE DESTRUCTION. EVEN TODAY
LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT THE FULL
IMPACT OF THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS. HAVE HAD UNTIL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS AND
HOW TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES HAVE RESPONDED.
HUNGRY RECOVERY PLANS ARE NOT
SHARED WITH THE P. U. C. OR THE
LEGISLATURE WHOSE JOB IT IS TO
OVERSEE THESE COMPANIES AND
REPRESENT THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
ALL WE NEED THIS INFORMATION TO
MAKE SURE GOVERNMENTS ARE
HELPING IN THIS REPAIR EFFORT
AND NOT IMPEDING RESTORATION.
AB ELEVEN HUNDRED REQUIRES THE
PC TO COLLECT INFORMATION AND
TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
AFTER EMERGENCIES OR DISASTERS.
I WANT TO STRESS THAT THE BILLS
REQUIRED REPORTING IS NOT
MANDATED TO BE SUBMITTED DURING
THE EMERGENCIES THEMSELVES BUT
IT IS INSTEAD A LOOK BACK TO
MAKE SURE GOVERNMENT AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR OR WORKING
TOGETHER. TO PROVIDE SOLUTIONS
IN THE SHORT TERM DURING
EMERGENCIES AND APPROPRIATE
SERVICE TO SUPPORT LOCAL
ECONOMIES AFTER THE DISASTER IN
THE LONG TERM. AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE REGULATORS AND
THE PUBLIC OFFICIALS OR
INFORMED OF TELECOMMUNICATION
SERVICE FAILURES AND NETWORK
DAMAGE AFTER NATURAL DISASTERS.
WITHOUT THIS INFORMATION
REGARDING THE METHODS AND
TECHNOLOGY USED TO REBUILD
THERE IS NO WAY TO ENSURE THAT
RESIDENTS HAVE THE SAME OR
IMPROVED ACCESS TO RELIABLE
NETWORK. FOR MOST CALIFORNIANS
RELIABLE VOICE TELEPHONE
SERVICE IS NECESSARY TO REACH
NINE ONE ONE. WITHOUT IT THE
ABILITY TO CONTACT EMERGENCY
SERVICES IS LIMITED LIMITED OR
NONEXISTENT. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TELEPHONICALLY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OUR LIST SORENSEN ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE. AND BRINDABELLA NUEVA
TELECOM AND REGULATORY ATTORNEY
ON BEHALF OF TURN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE US A-
ORGANIZE PRESENTATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL NUNN AND
OPPOSITION- WE WILL ASK THAT
THE ORGANIZED PRESENTERS LIMIT
THEIR- COMMENTS AT THREE
MINUTES COMBINED SO IT'LL BE A
MINUTE AND A HALF PER SPEAKER.
WILL BEGIN WITH A LOCAL LIST
SORENSON A ONE HALF MINUTES IS
SESSION ONLINE SHE PRESENT. YES
I AM GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI
MY NAME IS LINDA SORENSEN ON
THE POLITICAL DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE. AND WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AT
ELEVEN HUNDRED WE AFTER YOU
COUNT UP AT ELEVEN HUNDRED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNICATIONS
AND BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE IS
FULLY AND PROPERLY RESTORED
FOLLOWING A DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY. HE DIDN'T BRING
MEMBERS ARE THE ONES THAT YOU
KNOW THAT ARE STAMPED OUT TO
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA TO RESTORE SERVICE.
AND REBUILD CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN THERE IS
DAMAGE CAUSED BY A WIDE VARIETY
OF THEM OUR GOAL IS AND IT
SHOULD BE TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
HOME EVERY PHONE IS BACKED UP
AND RUNNING IN THE SHORTEST
TIME POSSIBLE. AND IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE. MEANS POSSIBLE FOR
LONG TERM SERVICE. YOU OFTEN
ARE NEVER HAVE HEARD FROM
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE ONLY WITH
YOUR SERVICE INTERRUPTED
BECAUSE THE MOVEMENT. BUT THE
SERVICE IS NOT RESTORED THE
ALARM. EVEN WHEN MANY OTHER.
ARE ON MY HE ALSO FIRST. THAT
SOMETIMES SERVICES RESTORED THE
WEIGHT THAT ARE NOT DESIGNED
FOR TEMPORARY USAGE ALWAYS AND-NEVER FULLY REPAIRED LEADING
COMMUNITY COURT. OUR ABU YOU
KNOW FOR MANY AND IT'S BECOME
EVEN MORE OF A PROBLEM WITH THE
INCREASE IN WILDFIRES AND OTHER
DISASTERS RIGHT NOW. A LITTLE
OVER SLIDES INTO. LONG TERM
REPAIR AND RESTORATION PARK
WITH THE NEW. IT SHOULD BE MADE
AWARE OF ANY OF YOUR VEHICLES
ARE NOT BEING BROUGHT BACK
ONLINE AND MUST HAVE HAUNTED
AND- EVERYONE IN YOUR- THEIR
SERVICE AND RESTORED BE MOST
EFFECTIVE. MEANS POSSIBLE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FORTY. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU NOW
WE WILL HEAR FROM BRENDA V.
ANOTHER. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
ENTRE MINIMIZE SOME MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRENDA
V. AND WHATNOT I'M AN ATTORNEY
WOULD TURN SIX YEARS A FEDERAL
LEVEL OUTAGE REPORTING
EXPERIENCE. TURN INTO PART
LONGER RADIO LEVIN HUNDRED AND
THINGS THAT SIMPLY MONOGRAPH.
WE'RE ALL TOO FAMILIAR SHE DID
STATE IN BUT THAT IS ACTIVE IN
OUR STATE CLOPTON TELECOM
SERVICE PROVIDERS NEED TO
RESTORE SERVICE AND COMMUNITY.
HEALTH HER EFFECTS. AND TO THE
CUSTOMER AND WE. ARE DEVASTATED
COMMUNITIES. CORRECT MAYBE I.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT THE
NETWORK IS VULNERABLE PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS DO NOT REQUIRE A
TEMPORARY FIXES FOR EXAMPLE
SUCH IS THE CASE WHEN A
TEMPORARY FIX USES
INFRASTRUCTURE ENGINEERED FOR
SHORT TERM USE. AND IT ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE FOR AN EXTENDED
DURATION. THEREFORE AND
MISSPELLED WOULD HELP THE CPUC
AND THE LEGISLATOR UNDERSTAND
WEEKS AND WHEN PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS REPLACE TEMPORARY
FIXES. AND NOT DUPLICATIVE OF
RECORDING TODAY NOR WOULD IT.
INTERFERE WITH SEVERANCE
RESTORATION. HI ON MY SHORT
ACCORDING TO THAT HE ACTUALLY
SEEN A FEW PVC OR CALORIE ASKED
ABOUT THE RESTAURANT DURATION
FIFTY SELLING WITHOUT REPORTING
SOLUTION. I MEAN THE THOUGHT
ABOUT PERMANENT SOLUTION. ARE
REPLACED WITH A NEW ONE
CONSOLATIONS REPLACE TEMPORARY
FIXES. IN ADDITION THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS THAT
RESPECT CONFIDENTIALITY AND
SUPPORT PUBLIC SAFETY DURING
AL STAGES I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL GO TO
SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT HERE IN
THE GALLERY DOES ANYBODY HERE
IN THE GALLERY WHICH TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF A B. ELEVEN
HUNDRED. I DON'T SEE ANY HANDED
SO WE'LL GO ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE. ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ELEVEN HUNDRED. AND THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF A B. ELEVEN HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. ENSURED ABOUT THIS%
TIME WITHOUT FIFTEEN IN OUR
QUEUE. FOR THOSE SPEAKERS COULD
YOU LIMIT YOUR- TESTIMONY TO
YOUR POSITION ON YOUR BILL YOUR
NAME AND ANY AFFILIATION YOU MY
HOUSE. TO GET IT PLEASE- CHOOSE
THEFIRST CALLER MR MODERATOR.
AND WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO TERRY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
MAILING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND SUPPORT.
NEXT CALLER. NEXT TO THE LIN
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SCIENTIFICALLY OCAL CABRAL THE
CW A LOCAL NINE FOUR ZERO EIGHT
NINE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY ELEVEN HUNDRED. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS LINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS YVONNE NELSON
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND I ATE
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ELEVEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHRIS BEAUCHAMP THE CW A LOCAL
NINETY FIVE ELEVEN AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
SCOTT TURNER I AM ABSOLUTELY W.
I. COMMUNICATION WORKS MEREKA
GASTRONOMIC AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF A. B. ELEVEN UNDER.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I THINK IT
IS EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS JANET WILSON THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS FALL. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO BE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THINK IT IS THE CAR CAMPOS
THIRTIES WITH A LOCAL NINETY
FOUR THIRTEEN I'M STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN HUNDRED-
WELL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WILL BE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DAVID LOPEZ
WITH COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF. STILL. EIGHTY
ELEVEN HUNDRED THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DEBORAH WILEY OUR FIRST
EXAMPLE YOU EIGHT NINE FIVE
EIGHT EIGHT AND I'M IN FAVOR OF
A B. ELEVEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. CONNECT TO
BE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS HAPPENING TEST-
WITH THE COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS
OF AMERICA LOCAL NINETY FIVE
TEN AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
ELEVEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. HELLO I. NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ELIAS ALL OF OUR AND A
POLITICAL TO STEREO FROM. NINE
FOUR ONE NINE FOUR TWO ONE. AND.
HI SUPPORT AB. ELEVEN HUNDRED.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
SIX OF THE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TINA
JOHNSON CW A LOCAL NINE
THOUSAND THREE AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT ELEVEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TEXAS NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BRENDA
RIGHTOKAY I'M WITH YOU TO BE A
NINE FIVE EIGHT EIGHT AND I'M-
AT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TRANSACTION NEXT IS
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN THAT COULD HAPPEN SOME OF
THE- BY MEETING AND I'M PART OF
THE. NEGATIVE THE NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS ACTING ON A AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
FROM COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL. NINE FIVE EIGHT
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO- SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION WILL
COME TO THE GALLERY HERE IF
THERE ARE ANY- ANYONE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AND WE THINK WE HAVE SOMEBODY
THERE. ALREADY QUEUED UP AT THE
MIKE. RICHER MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MCH BURNING A ROSTER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AD
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY. OKAY THE ROOM ONE
TWELVE NOBODY IS PRESENT WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE- Q. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED PLEASE. AND NOW HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ONE
ZERO PROPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. VERY
WELL- WILL COME TO THE FLOOR
MEMBERS OF THE FLOOR ANYBODY.
WISHING TO MAKE COMMENTS OR
MAKE A MOTION. US SENATOR BAKER
IF I HAD A QUESTION I KNOW
THERE'S A MEMORANDUM
CONFIDENTIALITY- COMMUTE. TALK
ABOUT THAT A MINUTE. THE WELL
THE TELECOMMUNICATION PEOPLE A
PARTICULAR AGENCY ONE MEASURES
CAN REMAIN CONFIDENTIAL THE ON
THE BILL WE MADE SURE THAT
THEIR INFORMATION WOULD BACK IT
UP. ARE THE IMPORTANT PIECE
HERE IS THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CPUC HAS REPORT
THAT COMES OUT TO US ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS SO WE CAN FIND OUT
WHAT THE BARRIERS ARE WHY THEY
ARE NOT REPORTING IT THE TIMELY
MANNER- AS WELL AS TO MAKE SURE
THAT- GOVERNMENT IN OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION PEOPLE
WORKING TOGETHER- IT COULD BE
OUR FAULT JUST YOU KNOW MAY BE
MADE MAYBE ARE FAR FROM PUTTING
UP. BARRIERS OR COULD BE THE US
THE CARRIERS. BUT WE DON'T KNOW
THAT WITHOUT THE INFORMATION.
KIND OF AT THE MOMENT DOES- THE
ADDRESS IS CONFIDENTIALITY OR
TO GIVE THE CPC THIRTY
DETERMINE THAT OME DATA MUST
BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL ST WITH
YEAH THERE IS IT DOES HAVE TO
REMAIN CONFIDENTIAL TRYING TO
FIND IT HERE IN THE BILL. BUT
SHE WAS GOING TO SAY THAT IF IT
IF IT SAYS SOME DATA MUST. GIVE
US IF YOU SURF ALREADY WERE. IT
YOU KNOW APPEARS TO ME THE
PRICE OF REQUIRE CONFIDENTIAL
GOING FORWARD BUT I'M GLAD THAT
YOU. DID ADDRESS THAT YEAH. IF
THERE'S ONE THING I'VE LEARNED
ON ON THIS TRACK IS THAT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY PIECE FOR OUR
PROVIDERS IS AT MOST AND WE
MAINTAIN INTENDED MAINTAINED
THAT THE KEY IS THAT THE IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION ON
WE'RE FINDING THAT MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS YOU KNOW WHEN
THERE'S BEEN EMERGENCY IT TAKE
A LONG TIME TO GET- THEIR
SERVICE BACK AND I WANT TO KNOW
ANYTHING OUR CONSTITUENTS WANT
TO KNOW IS THAT THE FIRST THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE GOVERNMENT
PUTTING IN BARRIERS. OR IS THAT
THE- PROVIDERS PUTTING IN THE
BEARS ARE GETTING THAT IN
TIMELY MAKING SURE IT IS
ADEQUATE IF NOT BETTER THAN
WHAT THEY HAD BEFORE. SO WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OF THAT THAT
DATA RIGHT NOW. M. A. D. YOU
WANT TO MAKE A PAYMENT TO THAT
THE AMENDMENTS WE PUT IT DOES
REMOVE THE- OPPOSITION FROM
AT&T. AND LIKE USUAL I'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU CENTERED
AROUND. WITH MOTION SENATOR-
BRADFORD THANK YOU I JUST WANT
A LITTLE BIT OF CLARITY IT
STATES ONE OF THE CONCERNS IS
THAT- REPLACE SCENE- DAMAGE
EQUIPMENT BY WILDFIRE WHEN
INFERIOR TECHNOLOGY BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE CURRENT
STATUTE THAT'S A LEGAL SO.
WORSE IS TAKING PLACE- I'LL
HAVE ONE OF MY- EXPERT
WITNESSES EXPLAINED WHERE THAT
IS TAKING PLACE. THE BLUES
COULD ANSWER THAT OR BRENDA. DO
WE HAVE A AND TO BE ANOTHER
LIST SORENSEN ON THE LINE STILL.
BUT APPARENTLY NOT. ANOTHER ARE
INDEFINITELY TURN. YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE GO TO. YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK THIS IS THIS IS PART OF
THE PROCESS HERE IS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WHAT IS MEANT YOU
KNOW IF NEEDED TO BE A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION TEMPORARY
FIX- AND IT MAY NOT BE THE SAME
SERVICE AS BEFORE. BUT IT STILL
FROM TERRORISTS IS NOT
CONTINUED IN THE LONG TERM-
AND- IT DOESN'T END ANY.
PRACTICE REFLECTION CONNECTING
THE NATION'S SERVICE BY WHICH
THE ENGINE IT IS NOT A LOT SO
THIS WOULD BE A WAY THAT TE
CPC AND A LEGISLATURE CAN
ENSURE THAT THAT COMMUNITY-
THAT YOU KNOW SOMEONE NEEDS AND
IN FACT. REVEALING WHAT IS WHAT
IS BEING DONE SO THAT THERE IS
NO- CONTINUATION IN SERVICE
WITHOUT. THE APPROPRIATE
PROCESS. I'M STILL LOOKING FOR-
IF IT'S NOT HAPPENING IN UNDER
CURRENT STATUTE STATES THAT YOU
CANNOT REPLACE- APPOINTMENT
WITH INFERIOR TECHNOLOGY I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE FOR.
CENTER BRAD WHAT AN IDIOT FIND
ME I GET. A PIECE OF BREAD.
THANK YOU FIND ME ON. THAT THAT
IS THE I GUESS WE'RE CONFIRMING
THAT THAT IS NOT THE CASE- THAT
SO IT'S A WAY TO PREVIEW WHAT
IS TO BE. I THINK GENERALLY THE
QUESTION IS IT NOT ALLOWED NOW
AND IF IT ISN'T ALLOWED. WHAT
IS THIS HOW DOES THE BILL THIS
BILL ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. THAT
SAID FURTHER ADDRESS IT DOES IT-
RESTATED OR IS THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL WHAT CAUSES IT NOT TO
BE ALLOWED IT I JUST JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF CLARIFICATION IF.
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION. YES MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT. IT IS NOT ALLOWED AND
IN IN. A LOT RIGHT NOW AND THE
BILL WOULD BE A WAY TO CHECK.
THAT THE PROVIDER IS NOT DOING
THAT. RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO WAY
TO REALISTICALLY AND
PRACTICALLY CHECK. THAT OUT
THERE THAT THIS PRACTICE ISN'T-
ISN'T HAPPENING. AND CULD YOU
AT LEAST TO PROVIDE US SOME
LEVEL OF UNDERSTANDING HOW THIS
BILL WOULD DO THAT WHAT. WHAT
IS THE ACTUAL. CONTROL THAT'S
PUT INTO PLACE. THAT WOULD
ENSURE THAT THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN.
YES THE BILL- OKAY WHEN WE TRY
TO MAKE A CHANGE AT THE PNC
WOULD COLLECT INFORMATION ABOUT
THE EVENT RIGHT ABOUT WHAT DO
YOU DO WHAT KIND OF THING-
FISHERIES ARE ARE PUT IN PLACE
AFTER THAT THE FIX IS IN PLACE
WITH A PERMANENT. PERMANENT
FACILITY. SO WE WOULD KNOW OR I
SHOULD SAY THE PC IN THE
LEGISLATURE WITH AND NOW IN
THAT AREA WELL THAT WAS- YOU
KNOW WHICH ONE- FIBROUS PUT IN
PLACE. OR WAS IT SOMETHING ELSE.
RIGHT AND YOU COULD CHECK WHILE
THAT AREA SHOULD BE SERVICE AND
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE SERVICED I
THANK. AND I'M BEING VERY
SIMPLISTIC HERE BUT FOR
PURPOSES OF THE DISCUSSION- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE
THAT WOULD BE ONE WAY TO I
GUESS REVIEW OR I WOULD SAY
ABOUT IT. THANK YOU TO CHECK
OUT THE COMMUNITY IS SERVICED
BY THE SAME ACTOR SEEMS
STANDARD THAT IT WAS BEFORE.
ARE YOU SATISFIED CENTER
RESTAURANT. SO NO BUT HE'LL
MOVE ON OKAY SO I WILL JUST
WANNA DISS SAY ANECDOTALLY I'VE
BEEN AT MANY TIMES AFTER FIRES
IN WAITING WAITING FOR PEOPLE
THEN WE GET LOTS OF PHONE CALLS
AND OF MY CONSTITUENTS BUT
LACKING SERVICE WHAT IS GET GET
THE GET THE SERVICE BACK IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY THE SAME
SERVICE THAT THEY HAD BEFORE.
SO THIS IS THE WAY THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THE TORAH CONSTITUENTS
THAT WHAT THEY HAD BEFORE IF
NOT BETTER SHOULD BE GOING IN
AND I DON'T WE DON'T HAVE A WAY
OF ANY KIND OF DATA AND THIS IS
A WAY TO UP FRONT PROVIDE DATA
TO SEE IF YOU SEE IT WE CAN DO
FOLLOW UP WITH THIS BUT-
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT IS
THAT AFTER FIRE AND WEATHER SO
FAR EARTHQUAKE WHATEVER HAPPENS
NEXT. YOU WILL FIND THAT WE
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
ACCURATE DATA THAT WE NEED TO
BE ABLE. TO MAKE SURE
CONSTITUENTS ARE CONNECTED.
THANK YOU- WE DO IT- CENTER
DOLLY. THANK YOU RICHARD I JUST
WANT TO FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
ISN'T THAT WHAT. THE RATE
PAYERS PAY TURN TO DO IS TO.
EVAN TO INVESTIGATE. WHAT THESE
SITUATIONS I BELIEVE THAT TURN
IS ACTUALLY WE USE RATEPAYERS
FUNDS OF THEIR NON- WHAT ARE
THEY THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NON
POLITICAL OR NON PARTISAN AND
THEY THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
LOOKING OUT FOR THE RATE PAYERS
AND THAT AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LACKING THE SERVICE I BELIEVE
THAT'S WHAT TURNED. JOB IS TO
ACTUALLY DO. YES AND THE ACTUAL
THE PERSON RESPONDING TO THE
QUESTION IS FROM TURNER BRENDA
BE ADVISED THAT TURN NEEDED THE
INFORMATION. AS WELL. THIS IS-
I JUST WANNA MAKE THAT CLEAR
OKAY SURE. CENTER GROVE. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIR I HAVE A
QUESTION REGARDING THE
OPPOSITION ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE TO MATT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
THE BILL WOULD DIVERT FOCUS
FROM RESTORING SERVICE AND
NECESSARILY- AN UNNECESSARILY
INTERJECT THE C. P. U. C. IN
THE REAL TIME PROCESS AND WE
HAD A DEVASTATING FIRE IN MY
DISTRICT LIKE MANY OTHER
DISTRICTS. IN BEING DOWN AT
COMMANDCENTER- I CAN IMAGINE
THEM STOPPING WHAT THEY WERE
DOING TO HELP RESTORE POWER TO
INDIVIDUALS AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND HAVING TO
FILL OUT REPORTS- THAT'S A
CONCERN I HAVE BUT I'D LIKE TO
HEAR IF IT'S OKAY FOR THE CHAIR
FOR BURNING ARRESTS A RISK OF
FROM C. C. T. EIGHT TO EXPAND
ON HIS OPPOSITION BECAUSE I
DIDN'T. UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
PURPOSE OF HIS COMMENT WAS. HE
STILL ON THE LINE DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION FOR HIM YES WHAT IS
HIS- CAN YOU EXPAND ON
OPPOSITION THAT HE HAS AND WHAT
HE FEELS IT WOULD BE EFFECTIVE
OR THIS BILL WOULD AFFECT-
SUPPLIERS. OR PROVIDERS. YES
PLEASE IT HAS ON THE LINE AND-
LEADER OF I JUST WANT TO BRING
YOUR ATTENTION ON A SEPARATE
MATTER. I HAVE THAT THERE'S
THREE PLEXIGLASS BETWEEN YOU
AND I AND THERE'S A GLARE. SO
NEXT TIME YOU WANT TO SPEAK
MAYBE YOU CAN GIVE ME A LITTLE
HAND WAVE A GESTURE BECAUSE-
I'M NOT GOT IT SIR I'M SORRY
BOUT THAT NO MISTER TERRACE MY
VISION I JUST THOUGHT YOU LIKE
SENATOR DOLLY BETTER THAN ME.
THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN. MR
LITTLE SCHOOL THE GOSPEL MOSCOW.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN A CENTER
GROVE- FOR THAT QUESTION- THE
INTERJECTION HERE IS THIS
INFORMATION THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION IS ALREADY
COLLECTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
SENATOR MCGUIRE TERROR
LEGISLATION ABOUT NETWORK
OUTAGES AND THIS IS FOR CAL-
YES EVERY TIME THERE'S AN
OUTAGE. EVERY TIME NOT JUST
DURING A MAJOR DISASTERS SO WE
HAVE TO NOTIFY TELL- YES ABOUT
THAT A RICH WHAT CAUSES HOW
LONG IT'S GOING TO BE OUT WHEN
WILL IT BE RESTORED SO
INFORMATION ABOUT NETWORK
OUTAGES IS BEING COLLECTED
TODAY AND THAT'S BEING
COLLECTED BY CAL OVER YET I
JUST WANTED YOU TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTION RELATED TO FIRES IF
YOU COULD WHAT YOU SEE IN THIS
CASE THE INFORMATION THAT FOR
RESTORATIONS DURING A FIRE
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO CAL- YES.
OKAY A SECOND QUESTION MISTER
CHAIR TOO AND THE OPPOSITION IF
HE CAN ANSWER IT IS AN SO YOU
JUST SAID I'M JUST CONFIRMING
THE DATA IS ALREADY BEING
COLLECTED AND IT'S PROVIDED TO
CAL- YES IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
RESTRICTS IN THAT BILL THAT YOU
REFERENCED A MISTER WIRE- THAT
RESTRICTS CALLIE- YES TO SHARE
WITH THE C. P. U. C. SO THAT
DATA DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
DUPLICATED. YES- SENATOR GROUPS
STATUTORILY AS TWENTY EIGHT AND
TWENTY NINETEEN THAT SP SIX
SEVENTY. HOUSES INFORMATION
KEPT CONFIDENTIAL BECAUSE IT'S
CRITICAL INFORMATION CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INFORMATION. SO
IT IS PURPOSELY KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL IT CAN ONLY BE
SURE TO LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES. TO GIVE THEM
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS ABOUT
THE- COLLEGE OF THAT NETWORK.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES KNOW
THAT NINE ONE ONE CALLS CANNOT
BE MADE. AND SO DURING THAT
ENTIRE DURATION WE MUST KEEP
TO- YES INFORMED ABOUT THAT
OUTAGE. SO THAT'S THE ONLY
SITUATION WHERE CAVALIERS CAN
SHARE THAT INFORMATION. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD THAT I DIDN'T
ASK YOU. NO SIR THANK YOU MA'AM
OKAY. THANK YOU CENTER GROVE
THIS IS A RECORDING BILL SO I
THINK GENERAL SENATOR STERN DID
YOU HAVE A- I JUST WANT TO MOVE
THE BILL. OKAY YEAH THIS IS
REPORTING BUILDING GENERALLY.
WHAT PEOPLE ARE ASKING IS
WHETHER THIS INFORMATION SEEMS
GOING TO BE PROVIDED AND IF WE
CAN- ASCERTAIN WHETHER THE
RIGHT EQUIPMENT IS BEING
CONTINUED TO BE USED AFTER. HIS
REPLACEMENT OR WHETHER- THE-
THE EQUIPMENT THEY WERE USING
STUDENTS JOB. BUT I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S ALL INFANTS BILL
NOT WHAT I'LL DO IS I'LL ASK
THE- WE'RE GONNA OUT DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I THINK
IT'S ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT
YOU'RE- PROBABLY GONNA ASK I
WANTED OFF THE AUTO TO SEE TO
GET HER PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT. THEY JUST STATED IT
SOUNDS. LIKE THIS IS ALREADY
HAPPENING TO THAT I'M GONNA LET
HER DO THAT AND- K. THANK YOU.
AND I'M GONNA ASK THE AUTHOR TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES IN
OUR CLOSING STATEMENT AS WELL.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT THE MOTION THE SECOND
PLACED ON THE FLOOR HERE. AND
WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER. SERIK
MAN. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I GUESS ALONG THOSE
LINES OF DUPLICATION BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S OR TRY TO AVOID IS
DUPLICATION- BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I. THAT I DIDN'T
HEAR IS THAT THE QUALITY THAT
IS HOPE BACKED UP IT DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE THAT DATA IS ALREADY
BEING COLLECTED. JUST HOW WENT
DOWN HOW LONG THAT WANTED TO
GET BACK UP. BUT NOT THAT IT
WAS AT THE PREVIOUS LEVEL IS
THAT WHAT I UNDERSTAND. EXACTLY.
AND I'LL TELL HER I HAVE HER
ADDRESS AT OUR CLOSING COMMENTS
AS WELL- THAT'S COMPETITIVE.
SO- SO- ASSEMBLYMEMBER CURRY IF
YOU COULD MAKE YOUR CLOSING
STATEMENTS I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION YEAH ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE IS
AFTER THE FACT THIS ISN'T REAL
TIME INFORMATION WE NEED WE
NEED TO FIND OUT AFTER THE FACT
HOW THAT WAS RESTORED IT WAS
RESTORED IN A TIMELY FASHION IF
IT WAS USED WITH- BETTER OR-
NOT THIS TOP QUALITY- FIBER. OR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WAS
INSTALLED BEFORE- WE'VE GOT SO
TO MANY CALLS FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS SAYING WE HAD IT
BEFORE OR BETTER AND NOW IT'S
EVEN WORSE THAN IT WAS BEFORE.
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
SENATE BILL INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE IS ACTUALLY ACCURATE AND
THE DATA IS THERE. AGAIN THIS
IS JUST FOR NOT GOING AFTER
INDUSTRY WE'RE NOT GOING AFTER
ANYONE WE'RE MAKING SURE OUR
DISTRICTS ARE TAKEN CARE OF- I
DON'T WANT TO HAVE BARRIERS FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS. I JUST WANT
TO INSURE THAT WE GET IT RIGHT.
AND LOOKING AT THE DATA AND HOW
WE ARE PROGRESSING AS
IMPORTANT. AND I WAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE GOVERNMENT IN OUR
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS ARE NOT
PUTTING UP BARRIERS AND MAKING
SURE WE HAVE QUALITY
COMMUNICATIONS IN OUR DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND THEN
WE HAVE A MOTION THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I'M SORRY THAT'S
WRONG MOTION IT'S TWO PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED. AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY THAT'S THE CORRECT
MOTION. AB ELEVEN HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR KERRY
DID PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY WESSEL
HI WESSEL HI. DOLLY NO. DALI
KNOWN BECKER. FIVE HI FORTUS.
BRADFORD. DOT BY DOT HI AIKMAN
BY EIGHT MEN I GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO TWELVE NO.
HERTZBERG. HI IS THE NIGHT HER
EXPERT HI. MCGUIRE MAN. MAN HI
RUBIO HI RUBIO I STERN. STERN
HI. CHIR NINETY TWO THAT HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO HAVE ANY UPS
AND MEMBERS ARE EX. WE HAVE ONE
WILL HOLD THE ROPE AND I'M
THINKING MACQUARIE STREET RIGHT.
HEY BUT THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT THANK YOU THE CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS APPRECIATED. WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT PRESENTER
SIMPLY MEMBER COLOR ON. A. B.
TWELVE FIFTY. THE BILL RELATED
TO WATER AND SEWER SYSTEM
CORPORATIONS THE CONSOLIDATION
OF SERVICE WELCOME. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT TWELVE
FIFTY WOULD SET STATUTORY
TIMELINES FOR THE COMPLETION OF
WATER SYSTEM CONSOLIDATIONS
THAT REQUIRE CPC APPROVAL.
CURRENTLY MANY COMMUNITIES IN
OUR STATE LACK ACCESS TO CLEAN
DRINKING WATER BECAUSE THEY
BELONG TO WATER SYSTEMS THAT
ARE UNABLE TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY IMPROVEMENTS TO
IMPROVE WATER QUALITY WATER
SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION HAS PROVEN
TO BE A SOLUTION. TO MAKING
SURE THESE COMMUNITIES RECEIVE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER
UNFORTUNATELY THE LONGER REVIEW
TAKES THE LONGER CALIFORNIANS
ARE LEFT WITH UNDRINKABLE WATER
AND RAPIDLY DETERIORATING WATER
SYSTEM. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS TO
CRAFT AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN THE NEED TO
HELP EXPEDITE THE REVIEW OF
CONSOLIDATIONS AND THEY NEED TO
ENSURE. THAT REPAIR COSTS ARE
REASONABLE. I'LL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TO TESTIFY REMOTELY ON A B.
TWELVE FIFTY R. EVAN JACOBS
FROM CALIFORNIA AMERICAN WATER
AND JUSTIN'S GARB FROM
CALIFORNIA WATER SERVICE. VERY
WELL- SO WE HAVE- SEVEN JACOBS
AND JUSTIN'S SCARBOROUGH THERE
IS NO NO ONE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION AND ORGANIZE
PRESENTATIONS WE'LL ASK THE
SPEAKERS TO SPEAK FOR A MINUTE
AND A HALF EACH THE TOTAL THREE
MINUTES THAT'S OUR GENERAL RULE
HERE. IN THIS COMMITTEE
BEGINNING WITH EVAN JACOBS ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. ELEVEN JACOB
IS NOT ON THE LINE TO HELP US
JUSTIN SCARRED. I'M HERE THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. AND IF YOU
COULD SPEAK INTO THE PHONE BUT
I BELIEVE SO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
SURE THING. I HAD CUT OFF ALL
TIES GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MY NAME'S JUSTIN SCARRED AND I
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING OUT
HERE BEFORE YOU TOAY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY CALLED
AROUND TO SOME REMEMBER CALLED
AROUND EIGHTY TWELVE FIFTY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALL CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION WHICH IS THE
STATEWIDE TRADE ASSOCIATION
THAT REPRESENTS WATER UTILITIES
REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION-
BEFORE GETTING TO THE MEAT OF
THE MATTER I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERONE
SECURING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. AS WELFARE STAFF
WITH TIME AND EFFORT THAT
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE
BILL IS A MYSTERY PROCESS I
DON'T FEEL LIKE EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AS ALWAYS IT WAS GREAT
WORKING WITH THEM- AS WE
APPROACH THE HEARING TODAY AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW EARLIER
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
RELEASED ITS NEEDS ASSESSMENT
AND IDENTIFIED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY WATER SYSTEMS
THAT ARE CONSISTENTLY FAILING
TO PROVIDE OUR CUSTOMERS WITH
SAFE DRINKING WATER. AND THEN
ALSO IDENTIFIED AN ADDITIONAL
SIX HUNDRED WATER SYSTEMS- THEY
WERE AT RISK OF FAILING A
CONSISTENT THEME THROUGHOUT
THAT ANALYSIS IS THAT THE
SYSTEM SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
SCALE NEEDED TO COST
EFFECTIVELY MEET THE EVER
INCREASING CHALLENGES OF
PROVIDING SAFE AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER AND IN SOME
CASES WHAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE
FOR THESE SYSTEMS IS TO MERGE
WITH A LARGER SYSTEM THAT HAD
SUFFICIENT SCALE AND PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF PROVIDING CLEAN
RELIABLE DRINKING WATER.
CERTAINLY BUILD TWELVE FIFTY
WILL HELP ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES AND SUPPORT THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER BY
CREATING MORE REGULATORY
CERTAINTY FOR THESE TYPES OF
INSTANCES WHERE THAT MERGING OR
CONSOLIDATION OF WATER SYSTEMS
MAKES THE MOST SENSE. I MEAN IF
YOU CHOOSE TO PARTNER WITH A
LARGER WATER SUPPLIER REGULATED
BY THE COMMISSION THEY SHOULD
HAVE THE CONFIDENCE TO KNOW
THAT THE REGULATORY APPROVAL
PROCESS WILL BE COMPLETE IN A
REASONABLE PERIOD OF TIME SO
THAT THEIR RESIDENTS CAN START
ENJOYING SAFE DRINKING WATER AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE MISTERS
GARDENS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOU IF YOU COULD STAY ON THE
LINE SIR I'M GONNA CHECK ONE
MORE TIME IF EVAN JACOBS IS
AVAILABLE IF HE'S NOT I'LL I'LL
GIVE YOU HIS. SPEAKING TIME. IS
SEVEN JACOBS ON OKAY. I WOULD.
SEVEN NOW THAN MISTER SCAR GIVE
YOU THE- OF MR- JACOB TIME IF
YOU WANNA CONTINUE SPEAK. I
HAVE JUST ONE MORE THING I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT MATTER
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
OKAY PRITCHETT THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS FOR COMMENTS.
WILL GO TO- ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. OF A. B. TWELVE FIFTY
A. B. ONE TWO FIVE ZERO FOR
ANYBODY- IT WANTS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT HI- I DON'T SEE ANYONE
HERE IN THE GALLERY. I DON'T
SEE ANY RUM ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF A B. TWELVE FIFTY MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE .
TWELVE FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE N. ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. IT DOES LOOK
LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT TWO IN OUR
QUEUE. WILL BE JUST A MOMENT.
WE'RE READY FOR SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT WHICH MODERATOR. AND
THEN WE'LL START WITH LINE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE WAITING SO EVAN
JACOBS HERE I GAVE THEM ON THE
INCORRECT LINE EARLIER. I'VE
BEEN HERE IN SUPPORT OF WHOLE
FIFTEEN I THINK JEFF KARP-
COMMENTS REFLECT OUR POSITION
ON THE V. TWELVE FIFTY AMERICA
YOUR SPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE
IN LINE ONE OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MEMBERS
CARRIED THE OFFENDERS WITH THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE AT THE
PC WE HAVE A REPORT IT'S A
MEDITATION ON AT TWELVE FIFTY
WE WANT TO TAKE A FAMILY MEMBER
CALDERON FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING
PROVIDE BUILT WITH A FOCUS ON
CHANGING OUR PREFERRED POSITION
TO A FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE IN OUR QUEUE WE
HAVEN'T ANY CAN WE TWO SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE HERE
IN THE GALLERY. NO ONE IS A
ROOM ONE TWELVE CAN WE PLEASE-
QUEUE UP SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
OF A B. TWELVE FIFTY. AND LATER
JOHN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE
ZERO PROPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN THEIR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY WILL COME
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE FLOORS S.
AND ROOM MOVE IT DOWN. OKAY US
SENATOR RUBIO. I CAN HOOK YOU
UP CLOSE GO AHEAD TO SPEAK INTO
THE MIKE NOW I WANTED TO MOVE
THE BILL BUT SHE- THINKS ANYONE
ELSE. ALL RIGHT- LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE A MOTION. AND THE MOTION
FOR THIS BILL IS DUE PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED. AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWELVE
FIFTY BY SAMBERG FROM THAT ON.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY WESSEL BY WESSEL HI.
DOLLY BECKER. BECKER I FORTUS.
BRADFORD HI. BRADFORD I. DOT
DIED HI AIKMAN. EIGHT MEN FIVE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH.
TWELVE HI HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG HI MY CHOIR. MAN MAN
I RUBIO. REVIEW BY STERN HI
TURN HI. ELEVEN A STIR. OKAY WE
HAVETHE BILL HAS ENOUGH TO GET
UP WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE UPS MEMBERS MOVE MOVE TO
THE NEXT PRESENTER TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A GOOD NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B. TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON A BILL
ON SMALL INDEPENDENT TELEPHONE
CORPORATIONS RELATED TO RATE.
MAKING WELCOME AND- PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN PROPOSES A
MODEST PROCEDURAL IMPROVEMENT
FOR THE SMALL RURAL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES KNOWN AS INCUMBENT
LOCAL EXCHANGE CARRIERS I L. E.
C. S. AS THESE ARE FULLY
REGULATED BY THE CPUC.
CURRENTLY THE PC IS REQUIRING
THAT THE SMALL RURAL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES SERVING THE HARDEST
TO REACH AREAS MUST FILE A
FORMAL RAPE CASE WHICH IS TIME
CONSUMING AND COSTLY FOR BOTH
THE C. P. C. M. THESE TELEPHONE
COMPANIES. FOR THIRTY YEARS
THESE RATE CASES WERE SUBMITTED
AND COMPLETED THROUGH A MORE
INFORMAL PROCESS KNOWN AS AN
ADVICE LETTER. THESE ADVICE
LETTERS ARE NO LONGER ALLOWED
BY THE CPUC FOR THESE RATE
CASES ALTHOUGH MANY SMALL WATER
COMPANIES. AND EVEN SMALL
ELECTRIC COMPANIES CONTINUE TO
USE THE ADVICE LETTER PROCESS.
AB ONE TWO FIVE SEVEN PROPOSES
TO EXPEDITE THE FORMAL PROCESS.
BY HAVING A DAY OF MEDIATION
BEFORE A NEUTRAL ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE USING THE CPU SEES
EXISTING ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS. AND TO MEET
AND CONFER PRIOR TO BRINGING
ANY MOTION. THAT THIS MODEST
CHANGE WOULD CREATE MORE
EFFICIENCY IN THE RAPE CASE
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT THESE
COMPANIES MUST FILE. EVERY FIVE
YEARS. SO ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS YOLANDA
BENSON WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION AND
PAM LOOMIS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES.
OKAY WE'LL GO TO YOUR SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT ORGANIZE
PRESENTATIONS AGAIN THE SAME
RULE APPLIES A MINUTE AND A
HALF. PER SPEAKER WILL BEGIN
WITH PAM LEWIS IF SHE'S ON THE
LINE. I ACTUALLY AM THE SENATOR
WAIT SO CAN WE START WITH YOU
ON THE BENSON PLEASE. HELLO
THIS IS STILL ON THE BED- GOOD
AFTERNOON A MEMBER NUMBER AND
CHAIR WENT THOUGH THANK YOU
FOR. ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF L. CONG IS THE SPONSOR
ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF EIGHTY
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN. AND AT THE
MOMENT HOW TO WIN INDICATED- WE
RECORD I REPRESENT A SMALL
INDEPENDENT TELEPHONE
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE CLOSELY
REGULATED BY THE FCC. AND
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN NEARLY MAKE.
A MODEST PROCEDURAL AND
TREATMENT AS WELL AS BUT
DISCUSS WITH THE MEDIATION ONE
DAY OF MEDIATION AND- AND ENEMY
COMPARE PRIOR TO BRINGING ANY
MOTION. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
HAVE COMEBEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE BEFORE AND ASKED
FOR SOME SORT OF RELIEF FOR OUR
RATE CASES AND THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE. SO I
DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT LANGUAGE
ALSO. SAYS THAT. HONG MESSAGE
THE IT IS MORE TO CREATE A
COUNTRY APPROACH TO THE TRADE
PROMPTED THAT PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. AND I WOULD I. HAVE
AT THE MOMENT PATTERSON FOR
CARRYING THE BELL AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AGAIN. BY THE
ME TOO ARE BALL WORLD TELECOM
COMPANIES AND I FEAR I FELT.
THANK YOU AND NOW PM. YOU READY
MISS LEWIS GOOD AFTERNOON. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CAMERA WOMAN
AND I REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANY AT. ONE THIRTY TO
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. AND OUR
HOPE IS THAT THE MODEST
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL WILL
INCREASE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE PARTIES IN OUR RATE CASES.
AND BRING A MODICUM OF RELIEF
FROM. THE BURDENSOME RATE CASE
PROCESS. AND MEETING FOR ME
PICKING UP THE PHONE AND HAVING
A FIVE TO TEN MINUTE
CONVERSATION WITH OPPOSING
COUNSEL BEFORE FILING A MOTION.
IF THE MOTION IS AVOIDED TIME
IN HALF OF THE STAGE FOR
EVERYONE INCLUDING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE TO
RULE ON THE MOTION. IN THE
FINAL RATE CASE PROCESS IF THE
WINDOWS TIME BEFORE EVIDENTIARY
HEARING MEN IN WHICH THE
PARTIES CAN ENGAGE IN
SETTLEMENT DISCUSSIONS. IF
THERE'S NO SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE ONE DAY
OF NONBINDING MEDIATIONS WELL
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT MEDIATION WILL
SEE. THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY
THAT A SKILLED MEDIATOR TO
FACILITATE FACILITATE
SETTLEMENT. OUR RATE CASES HAVE
NOW BEEN TAKING UP TO TWO YEARS
TO COMPLETE WE DON'T THINK IT'S
TOO MUCH TO ASK FOR AT LEAST
pPOSSIBILITY OF AVOIDING THE
EXPENSE AND BURDEN OF A FULLY
LITIGATED RAPE CASE. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE ASK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. EIGHTEEN
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW BUT WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. I DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
I'M SORRY WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT HI SKIP THAT PROCESS.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT FOR THOSE THAT WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IT'S TIME NOW
ON A. B. TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE V. TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN Q. CLEVELAND INDIANS WILL GO
TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION OPPOSITION THERE
ARE NO OTHER INDIVIDUALS
PRESENT IN THE GALLERY OR IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE PLEASE QUEUE-
MR MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION TO A B. TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN. AFTER AN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
CAN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY
WE'LL COME TO MEMBERS WILL COME
TO THE COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO
SAY BEFORE I- CALL ON SENATORS-
WE WE'VE TRIED TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE IN THE PAST AND I WORKED
WITH SENATOR BOARD JUST ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO ON A ON A VERY
SIMILAR MEASUREMENTS
FORTUNATELY. HE DIDN'T GET TO
WHERE WE WANTED TO GO BUT I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT IT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED SOMEHOW WE NEED
TO PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF RELIEF
AND ASSISTANCE TO THE SMALL
INDEPENDENT UTILITIES BECAUSE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING- THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND REALLY
PROVIDING THIS- TELEPHONE
SERVICE AND REALLY HARD. TO
SERVE AREAS SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE. YOUR WORK AT SOME
LEVEL. FROM NOT A RADIO CALL
ARTHUR I'D LOVE TO BE ONE I WAS
A CO AUTHOR ON CENTER BOARD
JUST BUILD I WANNA. HELP THIS
BILL ALONG AS MUCH AS I CAN
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A- A VERY
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE NEED TO
WORK ON THIS LIST OF
LEGISLATURE. SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MR CHERRY
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH YOUR
AN ASSESSMENT OF THIS BILL AND
I MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE OF THE
MEMBERS. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
DID YOU WANNA MAKE A CLOSING.
COMMENTS WERE SENT OUT IN A
PRIVATE PERSON. SPANISH GERMAN
GLADLY THEY HAVE HERE IN THE-
SUPPORT IN AND OUT OF THE SHIP
AS WELL THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS BUT VERY BRIEFLY WHAT
BROUGHT ME TO THIS WAS THE
EXPERIENCE OF A SMALL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANY
TELEPHONE COMPANY. JUST OUTSIDE
OF FRESNO AND YEARS AT A RATE
PROCESS THEY WERE WANTING TO
GET A RATE DECISION SO THAT
THEY COULD THEIR THEIR BANKS
WOULD HELP THEM THEY WOULD GET
FINANCING FOR CONSTRUCTION AND
IMPROVING. TO THOSE THAT THEY
COMMUNICATED WITH AND THOSE
THAT THEY SERVE AND WHAT TOOK
SO LONG THAT- THE BANK
COMMITMENTS I WENT AWAY THEIR
FINANCING WENT AWAY IT WAS A
DIFFICULT PERIOD OF TIME. THIS
pPROCESS PARTIES WOULD HAVE BEEN
ON BOTH SIDES THERE WAS A AN
APPLE AND THOROUGH METHODOLOGY
FOR THEM TO MEET CONFER AND GET
TO A DECISION QUICKLY- AND SO I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
AND THANK YOU MR CHAIR FOR YOUR
KIND REGARDS. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL COME TO- THE
MOTION OF THE MOTIONS TO PASS
ROUTE WE REFER. TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
CLICK PLEASE CALL. THE MEMBERS.
AB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON THE
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL. WETZEL HI DOLLY HI
KELLY HI BAKER I BAKER I
BRIDGES ARE. PURCHASE HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I HOUGHT I
DIED HI AIKMAN I EIGHT MEN I
INTELLISTATION GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH HI GROVE I HEARD SPURRED
BY HERZBERG I REQUIRE. MAN MAN
HI RUBIO HI RUBIO I STERN HI
STERN. FIVE OKAY WELL THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER WILL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMPLER
MEMBER WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE A. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VEHICLE WHO ARE. RELATING TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
THAT PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MAYBE
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS
IMPORTANT BILL THAT ADVANCES
THE GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY IN THE
OPERATIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND WE'LL GUARANTEE APPROPRIATE
AND SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENT FOR
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS FOR EVERY KID
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE.
SPECIFICALLY AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WILL REQUIRE AT
LEAST ONE CPUC APPOINT
APPOINTEE TO RESIDE IN EACH OF
THE FOLLOWING AREAS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. CENTRAL VALLEY AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
SIMILAR TO THE CURRENT REGIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE
BOARD. EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE WOMAN SURE THE COMMISSION
HAS FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH
ALL REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA. IT
WILL FURTHER GUARANTEE
APPROPRIATE AND SUSTAINABLE
INVESTMENT FOR INJURY ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY WITH ME TODAY ON THE
PHONE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS
EDUARDO INTERIM DIRECTOR.
OFFICE OF THE COMMUNITY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO. EVERYBODY HEAR ME L. SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF ONE SILAS-
THAT IS SPEAKING IN. IN SUPPORT
THERE NO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
SO WE WILL GIVE A MISTER
GONZALEZ A FULL THREE MINUTES
FOR HIS PRESENTATION. MISTER
GONZALEZ ARE YOU IN THE
LANCASHIRE. YES. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
AVAILABLE ON SUNDAYS ON THE
INTERNET SECTOR DIRECTOR AT THE
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ACROSS THE
STATE AND REPRESENTING THE
COMPANY PARTNERSHIP PLEASE HELP
KEEP ALEX'S BABY FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
BILL TO INSURE THE CPUC
CONSIDERS THE NEEDS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND EVERY
COMMUNITY ACROSS CALIFORNIA NOT
JUST LOOK BACK TO LIVE. IN THE
BAY AREA. KEEP DECISIONS AFFECT
EVERY PERSON THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT
THE COMMISSION HAS FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE WITH ALL REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
PARTICIPANTS THANK YOU VALLEY
PROVIDES AN ORGANIZATIONAL
FRAMEWORK FOR CONNECTING
COLLABORATING AND ADVOCATING.
TO IMPROVE ISSUES IMPACTING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE. ABOUT
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION FOR
THE EIGHT COUNTY CENTRAL REGION
OUT OF STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
MEMBERS REPRESENTING PUBLIC
PRIVATE SECTORS. WHICH SIXTY
TWO CITIES AND MORE THAN FOUR
MILLION RESIDENTS WHO CALLED
THANK YOU VALLEY HOME IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IS STILL
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
CHALLENGERS. HE COMPARED TO THE
REST OF THE COMPARISON TO THE
REST OF THE STATE. SPECIFICALLY
THE BAIL OUT THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED WILL REQUIRE AT LEAST
ONCE A FEW PEOPLE APPOINTED TO
RESIDE IN EACH OF THE FOLLOWING
AREAS. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SOUTHERN%
CALIFORNIA. THAT VERY SIMILAR
TO THE CURRENT REGIONAL
REQUIREMENTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. BUT YOU CAN REACH A
REPRESENTATION WILL PROVIDE
DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT. IT MORE
EXPENSIVE. TECHNOLOGIES CHILEAN
INDUSTRY EXPERIENCES AND BRING
TO BEAR HOT POSITION. OF BRAKE
PROBLEMS ACROSS THE LAST
SIXTEEN YEARS CAN YOU BELIEVE
THAT. ONE SINGLE COMMITTEE. AT
THE DEPARTING FROM TIME VALLI.
EITHER RULE TOWN OR LOW INCOME
OR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY IT
IS TIME THAT THE DECISION
MAKERS AT THE CPC TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS AND
CHALLENGES. OUR STATE. BY
ENSURING THE COMMISSION HAS
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH ALL
REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA WE CAN
FURTHER GUARANTEE APPROPRIATE.
AND SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENT IN
OUR ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. SHE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL GO TO SPEAKERS. IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE I DON'T SEE
ANYONE PRESENT HERE IN THE
GALLERY NO ONE IS IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE. AND IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THEN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. WE
DO HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE.
BORDERLINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS THAT AND MY NAME IS
NICOLE MAY NOT NOT MESS WITH
ANY OF GAS AND ELECTRIC AND
SUPPORT. EACH ANYONE ELSE
NOTICE THE KERR AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE-
PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY WELL I
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
EITHER AND ONE TWELVE CAN-
MODERATOR QUEUE PLEASE QUEUE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. OF A.
B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE. AND IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. CAN ONE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. VERY WELL-
WILL COME TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. DID ANYONE WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL OR MOVE THIS
BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION. OF A
SIMILAR NUMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
STRICTLY ASTRONOMICAL STRIKE
YOU WERE MUCH THOSE ARE ALWAYS
THE MOST ELOQUENT. A VERY WELL-
WE HAVE EMOTIONS BUILD DO PASS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS. A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY CELL
NUMBER VIA PADILLA. MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION WESSEL. WESSEL HI
DOLLY BY KELLY HI BECKER.
PORGES ARE GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD
OUR RADFORD I THOUGHT. DOT FIVE
FIGMENT HI. EIGHT MEN FIVE ONE
DOLLARS. GROW HI TWELVE HI
HERTZBERG. HI MY CHOIR. MAN MAN
HI RUBIO HI RUBIO BY STERN. THE
NATION. OKAY IT HAS ENOUGH
VOTES I WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THAT
BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
CALENDAR- SO- BUT- IF WE CAN
PLEASE RESURGENCE OF WE CAN
CALL THE ABSENT. FIVE MEMBERS
TO THE FLOOR FOR THE FINAL
TALLY- WHAT WE WAIT. I JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
WORKING WITH US THROUGH THIS
DIFFICULT PROCESS- I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS SO THEY COULD BE
ADDED TO THE FILE. YOU CAN ALSO
VISIT OUR WEBSITE- AND COMMENT
THERE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE REALLY WANT TO CLOSE
YOUR TESTIMONY. IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION- WHILE
WE WAIT FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA.
AND
CLICK PLEASE. CALL THE UPS
MEMBERS ON A B. ELEVEN HUNDRED
PLEASE. AB ELEVEN HUNDRED BY
SOMEONE NUMBER AG ARE CARRIED
TO PASS AS AMENDED. PORCHES
BRADFORD BRADFORD HI MCGUIRE.
MY NAME CLICK ON ITEM NUMBER
THREE A B. TWELVE FIFTY BY
SSEMBLYMEMBER CULTURE ON COUD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS.
AB TOP FIFTY BY SEVEN MEMBER
CALLED ON DID PASS AS AMENDED.
ALI BARGES FIVE PORCHES HI
MCGUIRE HE- WILL KEEP THE ROLE
PREFER ABSENT MEMBERS.
IT'S
BEEN I DON'T KNOW MAYBE FIVE
YEARS SINCE YOU'VE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE IT SEEMS LIKE. IS IT
HAPPENS AT EVERY MEETING. OKAY
HERE WE GO- I DON'T NUMBER TWO
AB ELEVEN HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR CURRY
PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS TH
TH. PORCHES REQUIRED BY THE
CHOIR I SURE THAT BILL HAS
ELEVEN DAYS INTERNALS OKAY
WE'LL CLOSE ROLE THAT BILL IS
OUT ON ITEM NUMBER THREE A B.
TWELVE FIFTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CULT CALLED ROOM PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TALLY
REQUIRE I REQUIRE HI. THE BILL
IS OUT. I MEAN IT WAS A CLOSER
ON THE BILL BUT I'M NOT A
MEMBER FOR A B. TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
UPS MEMBERS REQUIRE HI. MISFIRE
HI. REPORTER THAT BILL IS OUT
WITH CLOSER ROLE WILL GO TO
ITEM NUMBER. FIVE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VIA PADILLA.
CLARK PLEASE CALL THE UPS
MEMBERS BECKER. GONZALEZ
MCGUIRE. HI MY CHOIR HI STERN.
ELEVEN A SIR OKAY THE BILL IS
OUT IT HAS ENOUGH VOTES WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE NOW WE WILL
ADJOURN OUR COMMITTEE. THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS AS WELL
OFFICIALLY ADJOURNED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EVERYONE.